hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse sorry about the delay I was
trying to get everything set up right up
something is making my fan run really
high and so I've been closing down
windows and I thought I had more time I
just would have restarted the computer
completely but I didn't want it to
affect the video quality because I'm
noticing like the last day or two
the fans been running pretty loudly and
there'll be weird parts of the videos
either recording or the streams where
things just kind of slow down a little
bit anyway I think it's working now let
me know if there's something wrong with
the quality and I'll do what I can to
get that fixed alright - hey everyone
see a lot of people in the live chat
saying hello alright so here's the plan
today we're gonna do pretty much what we
did yesterday
maybe we'll get into some different
things but we're still gonna keep
working on this this site and if you're
just joining us for the first time or
you haven't been around for a while this
is working with reacts we're working
with graph QL next j/s we're using
WordPress as a headless CMS so we have a
lot going on we're doing some transfer
data from one database to another so
we're gonna do a little bit of you know
whatever we need to do today to get
things moving so I had a meeting this
morning and I kind of reported on our
progress for the site and I think most
of the people were impressed by how it's
coming there they're anxious to see
something so it would be cool to get it
to a point where
it be reasonable to allow other people
to see it and test it right
hey Gideon's here I haven't seen getting
in in here for a while
how's it going getting in your stock
videos broken I don't know the video is
broken again huh
I just don't understand
alright yeah let me switch to the other
let's switch to this screen did any of
you see the the switch let me know right
now you should see me really small down
in the corner and then you should see
the the desktop on one of my screens
all right everybody yay looks like
everyone can see me well I don't want to
say everyone
some of you can see all right so my fan
on my computer is still running you know
free loudly which is weird
so I'm just I'm still really not sure
what the problem is with that but if
it's fine for most people then we'll go
with it and
so sorry about the delay that's gonna be
terrible in the recording but at least
anybody watching could just skip ahead I
guess Rumble bro says if you're using
OBS drop the video encoding level down a
notch yeah I'm gonna have to do that
it's just we I've been using the same
settings for the last six months and and
they've been fine I haven't changed
anything in fact I've actually doubled
the amount of RAM I have in my machine
so it's just odd that all of a sudden
I'm having these problems so it may be
after the stream I'll check out my
settings lower them a little bit and see
see if I can get a better result I
definitely want to keep 1080p quality
didn't it makes the code so much easier
to read I'm running right now
Harshit said check the task manager i
i've checked the task manager for for
chrome while the chrome tab manager i've
checked that and got rid of pretty much
everything i'm down to just a few tabs
up but now you know i have to have
youtube up i have to have the stuff up
that I'm working with pretty much
everything else is closed right now I
got I'm gonna I closed slack let me
close my email using outlook for work
I'm just gonna close everything let me
close out Chrome Canary so I'm not using
it right now OBS
yeah there's just there's not much else
that I could even close out
I mean maybe I have I do have a lot of
projects open in Visual Studio code but
I'm working on all those projects all
right okay I'm not gonna check it all
out during the stream if it starts to
get bad I'll go back and check things
out but thanks I will check the resource
monitor on Mac and so thanks thanks for
the advice
Rumble Bros and all right cool I'll make
sure I go back through and reread this
advice when when the streams over and
I'll work on it what's this good turn
harsh it says go to the terminal and
type talk all right
Oh a nice horseshit awesome haha I never
knew you could do that alright well
let's check this out so here's a really
good tip we can see what's going on here
all right
helper so I'm guessing that code helper
has something to do with Visual Studio
code and that is taking out by far the
most oh it's just well chrome is taking
up the most it looks like but I can't
really do much about the windows I have
open now so I need them open all right
let's see what I have running on Visual
Studio code and what I can shut down I
do have let's see what I don't need I
need this
and there's my other stuff
did they not open
when I restarted all my code windows
there they are
alright I worried for a second I'd lost
everything all right so this is alright
I was working on this but I'm not gonna
work on it for the streams I'll shut
that down we will use this one to make
that bigger and we will use let's see
what if I have any other things running
here no it shouldn't have anything
running all right let me let me close
out of that for a second because I do
want to run we're gonna need to run this
anyway so I'll just get it started right
now and then I can start and grub
so I'm going to paste this in the live
chat
okay Blake's asking about what I have
yeah I have I upgraded to 32 gigs of ram
sometime within the last six months or
so let me see what the rest is about
this Mac I'll move it over here it's
it's really small though I doubt you'll
be able to see the text but yeah so I've
32 gigs of RAM Intel Core i7 2 gigs
graphics alright
yeah I mean that seems like it should be
able to handle live-streaming something
especially since I've done it yeah but
I'm still it looks like I'm still
dropping some frames dropped in like 2%
of the frames I need to learn more about
how video works if I'm gonna livestream
every day then maybe I oughta learn how
to do this properly
alright so sorry for all the trouble
I'll just have to dig more into this at
some point hopefully we've closed out
enough things that we can just work let
me I don't need this open you don't
really need that open we are gonna work
with this and what's this migrate you
yet we are working with this so let's
leave this open and I guess I can close
this uh you need one time or open so
I'll leave that open and I don't really
need this Trello board right now what
are we getting Duff we're getting down
pretty lean here not much else I can do
all right
all right harsh it's asking about the
encoding format that I'm using and see
trying to find it I don't remember
offhand what I was using and now I can't
remember where it's at in my settings
all right
know what looks like looks like it's
it's okay now all right yeah let's get
to work
good good idea hard [ __ ] alright so
let's at least get this open so here's
our site and there's our cue dog this is
what we had done just kind of get up
with a little lay out here still haven't
had a chance to throw this to my boss
I'm gonna try I tried to go and earlier
to see him and he had already left for
lunch so I'm gonna try after the stream
today and see if he's in he's just been
really busy lately with meetings and
stuff so let's see yeah so we have some
work to do oh I do want to show you
before I forget let me show you the
github repo now because I've updated a
lot of things I think that's to show
y'all yesterday I may have but oops
forgot to start the Pomodoro timer let's
start that up and
[Music]
so just to let everyone know we have a
project now and you can check this out
you can check things out here or if you
just want to go to the issues tab
there's a bunch of issues open if
anyone's interested in in trying to
contribute to a project you'll go ahead
if you're new and you've never
contributed to a project before check
these out you can ask me I'd be happy to
help you get your first github pool
requests merged so I'm gonna eventually
go through these but I'm gonna hold off
a little bit and then that way if
anybody does want to contribute these
are kind of all laid out you know what
needs to be done if you're not exactly
sure what needs to be done just you know
leave a comment on that issue and then I
can give you more information for that
so what I think we should do now is let
me make sure I'm on the right network
all right cool let's grab some some more
data and bring over you see what I don't
want to bring over let's see if we can
bring over our department pages out of
desertion for food animated movies oh
alright
actually we do have a question about one
of these issues now and that's a really
good question I I should have put this
in here anyway there we are so for this
issue on click the search icon and the
top bar should expand to reveal a text
field so let's let's find a project that
this happens on it was the bulletin
wasn't it see if I have this out here
already
I don't think I do I believe we had this
working properly on the bulletin yeah
let's try that out let me make this a
bit bigger for anybody who's not
familiar with using the command line
this will be kind of like a little intro
because I'm going to do some basic stuff
and then I'm gonna do some just a few
you know commands with like starting
your server up so we're gonna CD we're
gonna go so we're going to change our
directory and I'm gonna go into my
projects directory and then I'm gonna do
an LS and that's gonna tell me
everything that's in my projects
directory and I'm looking for something
that's bulletin so bulletin reactors the
folder I'm looking for so I want to see
the end of their bulletin react notice I
didn't type it all out
I am typed in bu L and then hit tab and
the rest of it auto-completed so that's
kind of a cool feature it'll save you a
lot of time typing and you won't make as
many mistakes cuz you're not trying to
type out the whole field so now that we
have this let's open I'm gonna open it
in a text let's go
[Music]
is package.json so I'm gonna open it in
this this little editor called nano is a
really simple editor
that'll open right right in our right in
our terminal you'll see so it just
opened here and I can see what's in here
I can edit it and it has a lot of the
you know commands you can use right here
a lot of the keyboard shortcuts but what
I want to see is what our startup script
is looks like start will work for us all
right so I'm going to close this out and
to close to close this out I just hit
control X and that closes out Nano since
I didn't change anything it didn't ask
me if I wanted to save otherwise it
would have asked me if I wanted to save
so now that I I know what our command is
we can go yarn start and we've already
set up this project to run the servers
so this is a little bit different than
what you'd normally have if you know a
project had been done whoops okay so it
we already had our main project running
on port 3000 so it has started our
project started service service started
on for
I'm afraid we're running the backend and
not the front-end one alright let me
just shut this down for a second if you
hit control-c that'll shut down your
server generally if you're in if you
have something running in your command
line you want to get out of it try
control see that works for a lot of
things so I'm going to restart this and
there we are this should be better
it's a slow go close here we are
oh no did we implement the login system
no um I said no I need a valid I'm not
like I'm happy that we have the login
system and that's that's awesome but it
just slowed me down here it's been a
while since we've worked on this project
I really do want to finish this up and
launch it but we've we've just gotten
sidetracked by these other important
projects and I closed down my email
which is smart
let's
when you open up my email again I think
I can get to it from here
whoa oh no I restarted so now even my
password is right here it's taking a lot
longer I thought
and I have to authenticate you've got to
be kidding me
it uses male trap oh I should sing it it
uses male trap
I'm trying to remember what we did I
don't remember for sure so are you
saying that we're it's not actually
gonna send the email yet and I need to
go to mail trap alright let's check out
a mail chat
alright okay so we did get it in my chat
let's see alright here we are yeah
alright so hopefully this actually is
set up or all this work has been for
nothing
alright awesome so let's zoom in here
and see how this works so we click on it
it opens up it automatically fills it
puts the cursor in here this is just a
basic material design style text field
but then we also have this close icon in
week so we can close it back up again so
that's how we want it to work
this is I would probably change this
slightly just I would want this to have
a little bit slower animation when it
opens up and it would be nicer if when
this opened the the X kind of looked
like it was part of this so maybe if the
X was here or if this was moved up a bit
so it integrated you know a little bit
better but basically like this is the
this is what I want so even if this was
implemented exactly like this I would be
happy and if we had time later on I
would just kind of adjust it slightly
but that's what we want so since this
project is using material UI the beta
version I believe it is material I the
beta version and it should be able to
copy most of that code and it should
work and all that of course is on on
github under the I believe it's bulletin
react is the the github project name
alright
horses suck about the masonry yeah the
masonry uses materialized yet for the
masonry stuff so it's a blend in
materialized
yeah hard [ __ ] it's I like how this
works right here
this is good the only thing we're gonna
have to solve and/or figure some way
around is right now on our main project
which we'll go back to in just just a
minute we have cards that are not only
different heights there are also
different widths so I don't think
switching to materialise columns is is
gonna fix that you know by itself
I hope I'm mistaken about that and it
does
we'll just we'll have to see we'll have
to mess around but I don't want to spend
any more time on the home page until I
show it to my boss see what he thinks
because we may just end up wasting time
on something that might not make it into
the final version of the site he goes I
think I would slightly lighten the
shadow under the navbar it just looks
too dark a little too dark for my liking
yeah maybe to see if this is basically
sorry
if you ever see anything in any of the
projects that seems like it's not in
line with the material design standards
let me know I will definitely change it
if that's the case so if this the shadow
recommended for you know the app bar
here is not the right shadow I'll change
it you know no problem
I just I want to keep everything
consistent so let's see we'll have to
look at it in our other project as well
and see if it's this dark I don't
remember doing anything custom to
darkness but you never know
yeah you're right Evo says it just looks
a little out of place you're right with
this elevation it does seem hard maybe
before I mean this this is still a work
in progress right so this isn't live
anywhere but I mean you can see this
obviously has an elevation but then this
doesn't and it just makes it it's it's
an odd effect here you know if we were
to like pan this and be able to look at
it like straight on it would be like
this is up a lot higher than this side
now if you know but from here it looks
like there could it's just odd right I
mean the way the shadows are there
should be something with the shadow
right either this should have a shadow
here or there should be some sort of
slight shadow on this edge so I I agree
I think that looks weird I'll have to go
back to the documentation see how it's
handled there and then yeah and then
we'll figure what to figure it out cuz
even you know right now the sidebar is
just completely flat against the
background right so it's it has no
elevation at all yeah left in oh whoa
we're not we're not working on this
bulletun project today so I'm getting
kind of sidetracked but I definitely
agree with you Evo I this this does look
weird and it kind of breaks the illusion
of the different elevations all right so
let's close out now look we're excited
sorry for derailing you from the main
site project die don't worry about it
that's I mean that happens it's I think
that's kind of how things always are you
see something on one project and it
reminds you of something else and you
end up you know going around to
different things so that's just normal
supported masonry to materialize
oh all right I just noticed this issue
hard [ __ ] so thanks thanks for making
that an issue
I don't yeah I don't think I made one
for it so thank you let's shut down this
server that was actually two servers the
front-end and back-end and now let's
start this one up again for a main
project alright so it looks good let's
verify that that is working and the end
Rock link still should work yeah Oh Eve
oh don't worry about being nitpicky I
mean I nitpicky is good nitpicky I think
is the difference between a good site
and and a perfect site writing a great
site because somebody will see that not
everybody but someone will see that and
if it's good they probably won't even
notice but if it's doesn't if it looks
weird they will notice and have a bad
experience with it alright so let's get
started we X in eight minutes left in
this Pomodoro session and I will take a
break and go back to the live chat
because there's a lot up top that I just
kind of skipped over John Hanson said he
saw it too
John you're your lite brite thing that
you made that shared on Twitter it's
getting a lot of love on Twitter it's
getting some retweets and likes and
stuff so everybody likes it so you did a
great job on that I shared it with some
of my co-workers and they were like
making designs on it and screenshotting
it and then sending on slack so really
cool
all right Evo says it's like that one
smudge you made on your car three years
ago which nobody else sees except for
you
yeah exactly exactly that's that's
definitely me I noticed like the one
tiny spot on a shirt you know that I got
like pasta sauce on a long time ago and
it always bothers me if I ever wear that
shirt like somebody's gonna see that
tiny spot no one ever says anything all
right so let's go first step is let's
figure out what content we're gonna
bring over once we figure that out we
have to figure out how are we going to
get all the content what fields do we
need to bring over we use our my gray J
s program to pull the data out of the
sequel server database and then use the
wordpress api to put it into the my
sequel database once we have it there
then we're gonna have to create a graph
QL query to get the data out and we're
gonna need a new page a new react
component to put the data in so that's
the plan once we have the data in we see
what we have then maybe we'll style it a
little bit and if you notice this we're
gone I'm not making these perfect right
we're just styling a bit so that they
don't look so terrible this is kind of
on purpose because I'd rather get a just
get a bunch of stuff in there be able to
show it to other people in my department
get some feedback before I do that
fine-tuning because I we have a tight
deadline and I don't want to waste time
so I'm gonna try to leave everything
really rough at first because if if we
have the data there and it doesn't look
perfect we can still launch and the site
will be a million times better than the
current site because it'll be fast
it'll be easy to find it'll be very
clean and not cluttered we can always
fine tune it later ideally I'd like I'd
love it to be perfect
launched but that's just it's not gonna
happen it's not reasonable given the
amount of time that we have I do have
hopefully some interns that are going to
start working for me in like two weeks
or something but I don't really know how
soon they're gonna be able to get in and
start helping so I can't really rely on
that to help speed things up
I mean maybe best-case scenario I get
all three interns that are considering
and they're great and they know what's
going on and they can help but I'm I'm
not planning on it I'm planning on you
know basically me and you all helping
doing all the work for the most part all
right let's see okay so let me get
something done in these last four
minutes here and then I'll go back to
lab chat and do the questions where's
our database I you know what it would be
better if we go Franciscan if we go to
the site itself it'll be way easier to
just pick it up then looking through
records in a database I want to try to
pick out main content sections so so far
we have faculty member profiles we have
the directories for the different
departments and we have all the news
stories so I want to try to just pick
out what's a section that stands out as
a really important section and I'm doing
it like this
because what if we can't get all the
sections into the site before we launch
let's make sure we have all the
important sections first and if there's
stuff that needs to come in after then
that's fine
I'm not worried about it so that's good
lemonade some information I'm mostly
trying to pick up things that would be
for prospective students if something is
geared towards like current employees or
current students I'm not worried about
because that essentially shouldn't be on
this site anyway we have another
internal site that should handle all of
that academic departments we haven't
brought these over I started to do some
work to figure out where this was at in
the database I think we should bring
these over these are definitely
important prospective students will most
most likely want to check out our
different departments and you know
figure out what we teach here so all
right so it's under the departments
let's go here this accounting business
administration economics
okay so departments ACC - be us
- EC really not like in that that URL
but we'll have to keep that in mind
because this is a place that I think we
do want to try to keep the same URLs
there's gonna be a limited number of
departments so if we have to manually
put in and change the slugs on these to
make a match I'm okay with that right I
definitely didn't want to do it with the
540 some news posts that we brought in
yesterday I'm willing to do it for these
departments though all right so let's
see I believe the content that we'll
want to keep over anything is this and
possibly this these are links all right
these are our links elsewhere just
making sure there's no toggles here for
the content these are fine these we can
recreate this and pull this from faculty
profiles if we want
let's see this program counting these
read more things I'm not really worried
about about this this is I don't think
this is super important to have
something like this alright alright so
now let's find where this data is so
I've done this is gonna slow let me open
up on another screen just in case I
don't think there's any private data in
this database at least in the part that
I've taken out of here but better better
safe than sorry so I'm gonna open on my
other screen just to make sure that
everything's okay and if it is then I'll
bring it over on this screen and show
you what I've done is I've pulled out a
lot of the data from that database and I
put it into a Google sheet so that I can
more easily sort the data filter it
search for things it's a lot easier for
me to do that in a Google sheet than it
is for me to come up with the correct
sequel queries so that's why I'm doing
it this way it should be in my recent
documents I hope
I believe this is it's a really huge one
so hopefully it doesn't mess anything up
alright good this is what we have
unfortunately I didn't bring over all
the data so it once we find what we want
were we're gonna have to try to search
for it based on the the ID which is okay
we're already set up with a query to do
that so I'm gonna try to find and let's
see let's just start typing in
business programs all right so we got
that that's definitely not it that's not
it
oops
hmm it might be frozen it is let me
refresh the page maybe I should pull
this into Excel maybe it's just too much
strain on on a Google sheet
all right let's exit that page and let's
pull that same data into Excel
it's asking me to update it I don't want
to update it yet
it's a Excel just opened up really huge
on my other screens I can't see the live
chat anymore alright if it says it looks
like the sequel query might have been
easier after all yeah I was thinking the
same thing alright so now I have this
open in Excel and let's do find are
there no keyboard short are you business
programs
there we are got it and
this is not good not good
all right well let's search um 222
yeah let's search for folder 222 the
reason I'm saying this is not good is
that this the different content types in
folder 222 they're they're not all it's
not what I wanted but let's just check
it out so let me find this is our
Microsoft sequel operation studio
let's get I always forget how to do new
query nope
I do a new query area okay
I'm gonna need to the easiest way is
just gonna be to pull this that way I
don't have to type it all out again and
so let's paste that in and use what I
want to see is everything and then we'll
we'll pair it down to what we just need
so we're gonna select everything from
the folder content or the table content
I'm going to share with terminology is
where the folder ID is 2:22 and I don't
want any records where the there's no
content all right so that makes sense
that's that's a waste we don't want
those so let's run that and it's gonna
ask me to pick the server and this is
the server
all right so here's what we're working
with I don't really care about these
right now content title and the HTML or
really what I want to see the most
sample
well
this is not as bad as I thought
all right actually it's this just a
little bit these are just menus
all right
all right let's think about this for a
second before you bring it over let me
check my timer it's got to be up by now
it is a I must not have heard it okay
all right let me let's take our break
right now I'm going to go back to the
lab chat this will give me a second to
process you know what would the data we
just saw what we're gonna do with it
when I when the timer is up I'm gonna
explain why I think this is going to be
a little bit of a problem all right so
let me scroll up and go down through our
chat also we have a major problem all
right it's good my spot if I wasn't
working now that it is so it we're good
let's see
all right the first half of everything
in the live chat is just about how the
stream was not operating properly
everything was lagging or stuck
so Blake asks if I've ever done any
social media marketing yes I have so
when I was freelancing so this was maybe
like two and a half years ago I stopped
well I didn't stop freelancing
completely but I stopped like actively
looking for clients I would do social
media marketing and pretty much anything
else that a small business might want
that had anything to do with the
Internet so social media marketing was a
part of that it's not my I didn't really
enjoy social media marketing as much as
I enjoyed other things it was I don't
know if I want to say was my least
favorite part of what I did but it was
definitely low low on the list of things
that I liked to do was but if you have
any questions Blake about social media
marketing let me know in my department
we do a lot of social media marketing I
don't handle it directly at all I have
access to our some of our accounts and
for like an emergency if several other
people in the department are all sick
and we can't get ahold of them then I I
can do it but that's not really my thing
but if I still know a little bit about
it so if you have any questions let me
know
Evo says that's the way I like to work
as well work out the base first and
start perfecting it afterwards with
clients it's usually that they find the
base good enough even though they said
it's home yeah yeah that's yeah I'm the
only problem I've had with that and I
still like to do it I think it's the
best sometimes you go in to show clients
or in my case other people that I work
with here they're expecting when you go
to show them sometimes they're expecting
too much and you're just showing them
kind of like a concept like first draft
type of thing and they they're really
disappointed and they start asking about
all these little details
and they kind of missed the point of you
know this is a big-picture overview just
to kind of show you what's possible and
what's going on so sometimes they can be
disappointed and get stuck on on some of
the little rough details so I do have to
like warn people going into a meeting
when I'm gonna show them this like hey
it's not finished it's just a rough
draft like if you see something that's
wrong like it's probably gonna be
finished you know I still welcome any
input but I do have to be careful about
that
I think I walked into a meeting one time
and somebody that is higher up where I
work um said they hated they hated it
they hated my project I think I had sent
a link out to it before the meeting and
then I found out that they said they
hate it so at the meeting I was very
careful to explain everything since I
knew going in that it wasn't exactly
understood that it was a first draft
Oh rook had to go sorry I I miss that
you probably already gone but by anyway
I'm sure you'll watch this later on
yeah Evo says wow that site took really
long to load I think that you're talking
about this site this main Franciscan web
site yeah that's one of the reasons why
I think anything we build will be
perceived as better because right now
the load times are so so bad I think a
lot of people don't even stick around to
see the site I'm not gonna use that as
an excuse to slack off I really want to
make a good site in its own right but
you know we have that going for us that
our site is most definitely going to be
way faster than this site I want it to
be faster than the most sites you know
out there certainly any of our
competitors other universities I want
this to be the fastest site Philip says
is that out of the box Visual Studio
code any special extension to get that
you yeah I do have some different
extensions so hmm maybe I don't have the
sound enabled on this let me refresh and
see allow notifications huh all right I
keep missing that the timer's up guys so
I do have something so my theme is ceddy
so it's SETI that's the theme that I use
and I also use a bunch of plugins to
handle react type stuff so if you look
up react is a react food truck I think
that's what it's called react food truck
is a plug-in that will automatically
download a bunch of other plugins for
you that all have to do with making it
easier to develop react applications in
Visual Studio code so I checked that out
I have very few additions to that set up
so
if you want your setup to look more like
mine then start with that and then if
there's something that still doesn't
look the same ask me and I can kind of
look more into my plugins I really can't
tell you what I have offhand I'd have to
look myself alright let's see oh let me
start my timer here
all right so oh I'm sorry I just saw
this this is really exciting so I'm
gonna read this comment John Hanson said
Quincy is going to put my lite brite on
free code camp as an extracurricular
project cool yeah all right
that's awesome John I'm so happy about
that
that's really really cool that's gonna
be a fun project for people to do wow
really cool really cool if you y'all
haven't seen John's lite brite project
on code pen check it out if you want to
link check out my my Twitter page I
write i retweeted something from John
that has the link to it yesterday so
it'll be in one of my top my top posts
check it out there and if you like it
give give John some love on code pen and
Twitter it's it's cool it's really cool
so let me let's go back to our data you
know quickly I'm going to do it
I'll be over here alright let's go back
to our data and I said this is this is
what I'm worried about this is my
problem so I was hoping that I could get
find a folder or something that had all
of the main programs in a folder but
that's that's not the case
what we have is everything that's under
like the business department is all here
but there are all different types so we
these are called Quick Links which are
basically just lists of of links which
we may or may not need I'll have to
check closer into these links now I mean
they might not even work with our new
structure I'm trying to keep all the
URLs the same but I don't think we can
keep all of them the same this address
finance classes text I mean and they
have text these are all text for
specific sets of classes up here we have
all these like programs that are really
kind of like sub programs underneath
this main header so this is kind of the
main thing and then pretty much
everything else on here is under that
you know it's kind of a sub section of
that so it's gonna make it a lot more
difficult just to pull all this stuff in
under one post type all right Vince just
asked if I could share the link to the
lite brite thing yeah on the next break
the next five-minute break
oh I'll find the link you know and I'll
share it
all right let me I'm gonna go over here
and see if there's anything that might
differentiate any of this stuff
it looks like these teasers are gonna be
pretty worthless so some of them are
some of them might be okay
all right well it looks like we could
get at the very least the text for these
different programs and I think that that
will be worthwhile
let's double check here so from this
main academics page these are all the
departments listed and then these
underneath here listed as majors
all right let's see what what the URL
structure is like for one of these oh
it's just a counting if there's not even
anything in between let's verify that
it's the same oh this is not this is not
good not good not good
I'm
I mean where are we gonna find this
this is gonna take a lot more manual
work
all right cool Vince found the link so
awesome Wow all right let's grab I guess
some different content because this is
just not and this is not gonna work out
I wonder if there's consistency
departments nursing okay
and now they have the major that's
nursing
all right maybe I should just go we'll
get some data from somewhere else
because this is a mess
looks good that makes let's check
academics
well we left at academic departments
already soon
so this is where all those majors pages
were alright alright so let's so we we
basically have to have two different
listings that have a lot of the same
information so all the majors that a
student can take are listed on this page
here then there's the other page that we
just came from the lifts academic
departments so these majors are grouped
into different departments but for some
reason the urls on these which should
say Francisca dot edu slash majors and
then slash whatever the major is don't
it just Franciscan dot edu slash and
then whatever the major is and that
makes it a little bit weird
in this the Oh the other thing that
makes this tough is within the same
folders which is really the only
reliable way we found to the pool in
data out like all of a certain type so
within the folders it includes both the
pages for majors and the pages and
content for departments as well as some
other stuff all right so here's what I'm
thinking what if we made a content type
to house both programs and majors within
that content type we had a category set
up and we had a category four program
and a category four major so that when
we go to grab that data for our our app
we could sort it out yeah we're gonna we
basically we could sort those out so
that we can just grab all the programs
or we could just grab all the majors
maybe we'll need to have I think we're
gonna have to have two taxonomy so we're
gonna need some set of like categories
but then also maybe tags that go along
with the name of a program because we're
going to need to be able to bring in
program info or links to programs within
those alright so we don't have to decide
that yet first thing we have to do is
bring the data over unfortunately we're
gonna have to manually check and say
which ones are majors and which ones are
programs because there's no reliable
data it seems that we could pull that
and do a pro programmatically so let's
test it by first bringing in this folder
2:22 that we found
bring in 222 see what we have
categorized what we need to and then get
rid of what we need to that'll give us
an idea of how long it'll take per
folder and then we can figure you know
aim is this worth it is this not worth
it
that's the plan
that's the plan for now all right so
let's go to our my gray Jas program here
let me make the font size larger and
we're gonna go to 22 that's what we want
we don't need a created I am gonna keep
content I'm gonna keep the content
teaser some of the teasers are nonsense
that they're not actually even real
sentences but some of them do look like
they'd be useful so we're gonna keep
them we want the content we want the
title Content ID alright good so we have
that this goes through and see all right
content title we are replacing that
that's going to be the slug for now
that's a no we don't need to do that we
yeah we determined yesterday that we for
the first for these and for some things
we don't need to change the title before
we put it in as this slug right and in
fact we don't even need to add a slug it
will be automatically added all right so
let's do it so we don't have to worry
about that at all
it really wouldn't matter either way but
we'll let WordPress handle how to
manipulate those slugs we're probably
gonna have to manually change the slugs
anyway
let me check my time here since alright
about 10 minutes and about 10 minutes
I'm gonna go back to the live chat I see
there's more questions in there and I
definitely want to get to them alright
we don't want the date anymore we are
gonna bring any excerpts publish title
content alright great this is what we
want we need to change the we need to
change the name somewhere right where do
I have it
let's I don't want that right now
why can I not find the place where I
need there we are there it is alright so
what are we gonna call this pose safe
I guess we're going to call it majors
and apartments
I'm gonna call it majors for now McCall
majors it wouldn't be that much work to
manually take a lot of the data out and
maybe make another post type for
departments and that might be something
that I could get someone else to do all
right let's do that so we're gonna call
this majors now we have to make a post
type for that so let's really quickly
copy and paste make a post type let's
see
so let's copy what we did yesterday and
make majors so let's not copy that
this is we add everything singular and
plural exactly the same this one will be
better
all right that's major and then all the
plural will call majors and then down
here we'll do the same
all right so this is a bit of PHP this
is a wordpress plugin so all we're doing
here is making a new custom post type
we're giving it some labels that will
appear in the admin panel and then we're
also just kind of telling it how it
should act the type of fields that it
should have available for users to edit
and where it should appear we want to
make sure it does appear in graph QL so
that it we're able to grab that data
from graph QL and we're also telling it
to appear in the REST API which right
now we're using a little bit just to get
a visual of what the data looks like but
may not need that when we actually
launch the site and all right so let's
say that I'm going to copy it and let's
go to our WordPress installation I'm
gonna log in and go to our plugins and
edit our plugins this isn't the only way
we could edit the plug-in but I haven't
really set up any other way so this is
how we're gonna do it for right now
whoops ah it's the wrong plug-in here's
our custom plugin all right so we're
gonna paste the new stuff update if we
have an error it should tell us
automatically and so it doesn't have an
error we do have this warning making
changes active plugins is not
recommended so we just did nothing broke
this isn't really a live site on a live
site probably wouldn't do that so now
that that's there we should be able to
run our migrate AAS program and
everything should migrate over yesterday
I made some mistakes this isn't work on
the first try so we'll see see if I
forgot anything this time
let's go node migrate J s yay cool what
works well I didn't realize there were
that many in there alright cool will
shut this program down remember we did
it we do control C and that shut that
down and now we can check our WordPress
installation and what we should have
it's a place for majors and if we click
on there hmm
nothing's in there what happened let's
double check our my grade j s file
let's said it was inserted but it
obviously was not
[Music]
maybe it's not supposed to be floral
let's give that another shot
there we are okay the so the problem was
I supposed to use the singular major
instead of the plural majors all right
all right two more minutes I'm going to
get to the live chat answer some
questions let's see what we have
header yeah I don't I don't really want
that right do you really want the header
I don't know
maybe it would be useful better right
now to not delete if we don't have to I
am interested to see what these quick
links are all right so these are
relative links which that's that's good
some of these are links to our we have a
an outside like a third-party vendor
that called Smart catalogue that handles
all of our our course descriptions and
things so those links will still work
alright it looks like these links will
still work
so maybe maybe we'll use them
oops and the times almost up so let's
well all the suet time it is alright let
me go to the live chat will answer some
questions while I'm answering the
questions let me know if you want to
continue on now and build out a page to
put some of this data on I'm thinking
what we might have to do is grab
multiple pieces from here to build out
the page yeah that we're gonna have to
build this differently than we built any
of the other pages I think if we want to
avoid having to like hand code anything
or make yeah it'll be a little bit more
work coming in but then I think it
should make things go faster as we bring
in the other folders for this so let's
let's give it a shot but let me know if
you'd rather wait and do that on a
different stream and we've already been
streaming it's about an hour and a half
so it's gonna end up being really long I
know it's getting late for some of you
so anyway please put in the live chat
now if you think we should just save
this for tomorrow stream or if we should
keep going today I I could do other one
I'm okay with either one all right so
let me go back up to where I left off
and get these questions answered
oops I'm gonna do a short break but if I
have to go over I'm fine with that I
want to get these questions in
Oh Eva says I have my first nan intern
job interview next Monday and I'm really
stoked on I am - that's really exciting
I don't know I mean I'm like the details
that you could give of that on the live
stream but I'd love to hear more details
about like what's what's the job you
know like and I give you know any help
I'm happy to give it
I am I I've obviously interviewed before
for jobs but I've also been on the other
end interviewing developers so I don't
know maybe I should be able to give you
some advice if you want right I'm no
expert I'm just happy for you and what I
hope you get the jobs oh I don't know
how helpful I'd be but that's really
cool definitely so when it's next Monday
all right you you have to if you get a
chance after the end of you come back in
the live chat let us know how it went
I'm gonna be waiting to hear if you
can't make it to the live chat like let
me know on Twitter or something
let's see Vince says that's not regular
HTML the element not in the head and
what is yeah there's weird stuff going
on with this HTML Harshit said that's
the beauty of ektron yeah definitely
yeah this HTML was weird
it's what if we could see where's the
business program yeah we should be able
to see some of the weirdness going on
here
whoa this one's not too bad these old
normal P tags get a be kidding me
hey we finally got something with some
good markup all right but but you're
right we haven't getting some weird
markup we've had to do some weird stuff
with data earlier like changing the
names of some of the tags with
JavaScript in our components before we
render anything using CSS to just hide
stuff that's just weird and shouldn't be
there so we have to work with this now
the plan long-term is to clean all that
up have separate fields in WordPress and
our post types for each piece of data
and then to pull that in and it'll be so
much nicer once we get that there'll be
no need for anyone who deals with the
data to really know HTML so it'll be
alright but we're doing it this way to
save time I I wish we had more people
you know that that worked in my
department that could do some of this
you know I could bring it in set up the
post type and then they could just work
on data entry basically but we just
don't have that right now especially
like the students are still on on their
break for Christmas and so we don't we
don't even have student workers really
to work on this
the ego says and this is in regard to
when I was saying that the current
websites really slows or the new website
anything should be an improvement so he
said yeah if the previous was really bad
then everything will be perceived as a
huge improvement it will yeah but not by
everyone there's a group of people at
the University mostly faculty members
that see any type of change as a bad
thing especially if it's a change in
technology so I'm sure that it will have
some complaints when it comes to that
but this sites not for an internal
audience it's for an external audience
so if anybody internally complains about
it I'll just remind them that well
that's that you're not really the
audience the audience our high school
students mainly so that's what we have
to keep in mind is what a high school
student look at this know what to do be
attracted to this so hopefully they will
be and I'm sure they'll appreciate the
increase in speed SJ says normally never
catch this live usually watch the
recordings the next day
SJ I'm I'm really happy you get to catch
this live welcome welcome to the live
chat and thank thanks for watching let's
see SJ says I wanted to let you know
yesterday when you had the weird slug it
was because you highlighted the - from
the beginning of the slug and physically
dragged it to the end of this look Oh No
haha and I didn't even know I didn't
catch that
well Thank You SJ for bringing it up cuz
I had no idea why it happened and then
why it was fixed so it must have just
maybe automatically been fixed because I
didn't save it and then when I went to a
different post it just reverted that's
probably what happened so Wow
good catch on that I mean that must have
been that's a small detail but I really
appreciate you
coming in the live chat and telling me
now I'm not gonna be worried about
bringing in the slugs and stuff that you
know because that was you know entirely
my fault
all right cool can't believe I made it
silly mistaken didn't notice it like
that but I really appreciate you saying
that
Vince says it says L oh you mean I don't
have to worry about running out of the
black pieces of paper with the patterns
on them I don't remember what I said I
don't I don't remember what I said for
that response so Vince let me know what
I was talking about
Vince says I'm new here
oh no you're talking about lite-brite
that's it okay took me a little while to
figure out what's going on so yeah if
anybody actually used lite brite when
you were a kid you remember like you had
the so you had the the box right and
there was a light bulb literally a light
bulb in that box and then this black
piece of plastic with all the holes in
it and then you would take a black piece
of paper that had a pattern on it and it
I think it had little letters to let you
know what color to put in there and you
stuck that on the grid and then you push
little plastic pegs in there and the
light would shine and the plastic was
like semi-transparent right so you push
the pegs in there and it would shine
with all these different colors right
but if you use the paper once it's done
for basically because you're not going
to remember all the colors and
everything but anyway so that's that's
how lite brite worked if you're not
familiar with lite brite but John's
version done in reacts on code pen is
entirely reusable it's awesome
let's see guitar 6029 says hello would
you say react is more popular than
angular yeah that's a big debate I can
only give you my personal opinion I
don't really know numbers for sure you
know but I'll say this react is for sure
growing in popularity at a faster rate
then angular is I see like just looking
at job I look at job postings a lot I
think it's a great way to try to keep
your skills in line with what companies
really want a lot of like bigger come
it's this is just my perception from
what I've seen so just you know realize
that it this is just me talking here the
bigger companies that switch to angular
when angular was a big deal like I don't
let's say like five six years ago or
something you know they made the switch
to angular that takes a lot of work to
make the switch they're not really as
quick to switch to react now smaller
companies seem to be switching to react
like obviously newer companies are seem
to all be going with react all your
startups and stuff and then smaller
companies that maybe either didn't do
angular are now doing react or maybe if
they're just more open they don't have a
huge code base and they're more open to
switching it over it seems like they're
going with with react more that's just
my observation from from job listings
right but I don't really know of any
like specific numbers is to like well
how many sites use angular versus
reactor how many companies use it so I'm
not sure if I had to pick one that that
has more momentum I put my money on
react for sure it just seems like you
see so much more about react out there
being talked about on Twitter you know
in blogs and stuff so it's not like
react is out or angular's out of the
picture you know it's definitely not
it's a big player a lot of
people use angular but reacts just got a
lot of momentum right now and it has for
a couple years now anyway hopefully
that's a good answer
I'm not I am a big believer and said the
idea that there's a lot of different
ways to solve a problem and you know not
not one one way isn't the way to solve
every single problem so for me reactance
is helping me solve a lot of problems
right now but it totally fine with using
other tools other solutions or if other
people look at the same problem use a
different solution it's fine with me at
the end of the day if you fulfill all
the user stories all the requirements
for the project and you know you've
really designed something that provides
a great user experience it doesn't
really matter what you use right it
doesn't matter as long as you don't good
code then that's that's fine everything
else is cool to debate but from a user's
point of view it doesn't matter at all
and usually from a client's point of
view it doesn't matter at all so don't
feel bad no matter what you're using as
long as you're producing good work I I
mean I you're where you need to be
alright if you're out looking for a job
and you need to know like who's hiring
what skills do I need that's a different
story but if you're already making money
and doing good work then you know I'd
say don't don't worry about what the
next best thing is let's see Phillip
says I'll say javascript is the most
popular yeah yeah guitar says everyone
is jumping on frameworks but never
learning JavaScript yeah I would say
there's some truth to that I I see that
that's sent that statement kind of
repeated
a lot of different places so I agree my
my take on this is when you're first
starting out
yes learn your basics of JavaScript
right but you shouldn't try to master
JavaScript before you go into a
framework here's why assuming that
you're trying to make money while you're
doing this and you're not a full-time
student that can afford to just take
your time you're gonna miss out on a lot
of money if you force yourself to just
use JavaScript and don't jump in on some
type of framework and just because you
go to a framework doesn't mean you stop
learning JavaScript my Pat if I was
gonna give advice as to a path to take
is learn your basic JavaScript enough to
be able to understand what's going on in
a framework then start learning the
framework but also keep learning
JavaScript at the same time then you get
the best of both worlds then you'll get
to learn the framework you'll start
working on projects like that if it's an
in demand framework you could probably
get a job or start making money at least
freelance with it and you keep building
up your JavaScript skills I learned a
lot of new es6 stuff when I switched to
react because it was being used in react
there's a lot of things that I never had
to do a lot of JavaScript stuff I never
had to use until I started using react
so switching to react actually helped me
and push me to learn more JavaScript so
I think that's it's good to keep in mind
that it's not like either or right you
can do both at the same time you know if
you do it right you can do both at the
same time so that's my official advice
but yeah I mean I agree someone
shouldn't just start out day one with
react right day one you start out should
be plain JavaScript stuff for sure you
need some foundation but just don't feel
like you need to wait you know for a
really long time before you switch
it's not gonna hurt your skills you can
keep on learning JavaScript and a
framework and whatever else you want at
the same time so I mean that's my
opinion based on my experience so I'm
not gonna hate on anybody that has a
different opinion all right let's see
John Henson says doesn't graph QL allow
you to make better queries that pull
only the data you need even if
categorized in many folders views it's
supposed to work better than just REST
API yes yeah for sure
yeah graph graph QL will let us grab
exactly the data that we want and that's
what will end up I think will end up
having a lot of really detailed queries
for some of these pages where we need to
grab a lot of different you know parts
of pieces of data so we'll have to
figure it out we're gonna have to learn
more about querying with graph QL as as
we go on and I as some of you already
know a lot about it I'm for sure gonna
have to learn more though Vince says how
do you build for a job like this it
looks like they gave you a password to
their database with very little
information about the database
architecture as an hourly all right so
I'm on a salary so I am a full-time
front-end developer for University and
I'm on a salary so I'm not billing for
this if I was doing this freelance
hourly would probably be the way to go
if I were to give a like a lump sum
here's how long how much the project it
would be huge it would be a big amount
because of the amount of like just not
knowing right so the reason I don't know
anything about this database structure
is because no one here knows anything
about the database structure the site
was was built by a company that we hired
to build it and so we don't know there
was really only one person ever
maintaining anything on the back end who
they don't work here anymore and they
didn't use any type of version
control for us to be able to go back and
see like you know what happened here so
if you look back on the stream we've
kind of looked at the back end of this
thing we've looked at the database we've
tried to figure out what's going on even
into like some of the templates that
were used it's all detective work right
now we're all like always just searching
like how is this going on so yeah it's
it's a little bit frustrating that we
have to spend so much time just trying
to figure out where this data is and how
it was categorized and things like that
but I mean that's that's the jaw that's
what we have to do so that's why I
really want to put thought into how
we're pulling this data in because I
don't want the next person to have to
deal with the same problem right I want
to have some logic to the way we
structure things and then that you know
this will never have to happen again
Vince says in the description it says
front-end developer at work but there's
an awful lot of back-end stuff going on
here I know it can't be avoided but
avoiding this is the reason I want to do
front-end yeah Vince I I agree so when I
first started doing this stream about I
don't know eight eight nine months ago
something like that I really did do more
front-end my title is front-end
developer realistically I've started
doing a lot more backend stuff as the
year has gone on you know potentially
depending on the company I may be could
be considered full stack it just depends
on you know how titles are in this
industry like they're kind of loose and
they're not really heavily regulated
right you know any industry that has you
know JavaScript ninja as a title you
know like titles homie that much so
maybe it would be worth changing up the
description on the video a bit to
reflect the fact that we don't just do
front-end work you know sometimes you
know we get really into back-end
working there are some streams where
it's just back in and we don't do any
front end so that's a good point
actually that's that's a really good
point I think I can't do anything about
my title but I can definitely change the
description to more accurately reflect
the work that we do on the stream Evo
says currently in my third year of
school but my capacities are hardly
reached in school so I decided to seek a
development job cool Eva says the job is
at a communication company whose
campaign new campaigns for
multinationals my task will either be
back end or front end with angular I
will hear the details next Monday all
right very cool very cool I hope it
works out for you and then you'll know
angular you you'll be like my person
that knows angular on the stream so if
we have to work with that I can ask you
all the angular questions let's see
alexey says are you okay you look kind
of tired I feel kind of tired um I feel
tired I had I mean I guess I went to
sleep at an okay hour but my my youngest
son was up last night and so I had to
get up and get him a drink or something
yeah I think he did he wanted to drink
and he just wouldn't quit crying without
a drink it was like he's really cute but
at in the middle of the night like
you're just so tired so I got up and got
him a drink he went back to sleep so
kind of had interrupted sleep so maybe
that's why I'm tired I didn't have as
much caffeine as I normally do today too
so that could be it so I apologize I had
like an energy drink before the stream
because I know it's no fun for you all
if I seemed like really tired and
during the stream so I try to stay
upbeat but I think I'm okay like I'm not
my eyes feel tired but otherwise my
body's like okay thanks for asking
though I appreciate the concern Evo says
the only thing I am currently struggling
with our questions from an interview but
I guess that is just due to lack of
understanding as to how they go to work
on projects yeah do you know at all Evo
if they're gonna ask you like technical
questions like algorithms and stuff to
solve because there are some websites
that are that help you to practice for
that kind of thing so yeah I mean you
they may not have told you ahead of time
but I can I could give you some links or
something the websites that will help
with that Vince says that's how real
life I worked back in the day light
behind the black piece of paper and you
poked holes in the color fake yeah yes
Vince don't worry about I I played with
lite brite back in the day that's how I
totally remember that I love lite brite
they look so cool did they still sell
those I don't know I think maybe I I
want to get it for my kids but my
daughter Cordelia is like a year and a
half old and I'm I she would definitely
try to eat it should try to eat the
little pegs and if not eating it she
would just throw him around so we'd
probably lose the pegs maybe I'll wait
and so she's a little bit older cuz
otherwise we would just lose all the
colored pegs within a week rumble Bros
says I'm having a hard time between
going full stack or becoming a back-end
developer only I know doing full stack
beads hmm sorry
I know doing full stack means I'll have
more chances but specialization is also
a good thing Rumble Bros I'd say
think about if you don't I'd say this if
you're okay financially and can wait a
little bit before like getting a good
dev job then do what you really like to
do the most if you really like back in
and you don't care for front-end stuff
stick with back-end and specialize get
really good at that
if you really need a job and you think
going full stack will will give you a
better chance at getting a better job
maybe you make it more money then go
with that you can always you know maybe
get to a point later on where you know
you have a job you've been there for a
year or two and you're comfortable
financially and then you can start
looking around for a job that you know
something you really want to do I'm I
don't know my dad always told me you
know you just sometimes you just have to
get a job it doesn't matter if you like
it or not he would say if it was fun
they wouldn't call it work so I still
have that in me a little bit that's like
sometimes you just have to do what you
have to do to pay the bills so I always
keep that in mind just kind of be really
practical and realistic about that you
know do that but then keep working
towards your goal of what you really
want to do so I don't know if that
really helps you you know in terms of an
answer but I mean I do know that jobs
for full-stack developers usually pay
more than for front-end or back-end so
if you're really looking for for an
increase in pay or something full stack
is probably where you want to go but it
may not be worth it if you really don't
like the one the front-end stuff all
right
SJ says I've never heard of lite brite
does that mean I'm young
Blake's never heard of it either oh man
no y'all never heard of lite brite we
have to we have to do something about
the
eat life right
let's see if we can get the library
commercial
all right here's library you're not
being able to hear the sound but this is
the original 1970s light break
commercial now I mean I wasn't around in
the 1970s I remember using lite brite in
the late 80s Early 90s but that's that's
late bright
and now I'll have to go in and check so
the free code camp YouTube channel
history will now have the light bright
thing in there's me let's see so if
you've never used lite brite go check
out John's version of light bright and
use it and then if you really really
like it you could probably find the lite
brite maybe they still make them if not
maybe you could get an old one on eBay I
should get a real light bright and have
it right behind me like on this shelf
and then I could write different things
that would be cool alright back to the
latch Vince says graph QL has to be
supported server-side doesn't it does
Ektron support graph QL as far as I know
Ektron doesn't support graph QL or much
of anything but we're pulling it into
WordPress and we have a plug-in called
WP graph QL that does all the work for
us to make graph QL work with WordPress
so that saved us a lot of time and the
guy Jason yeah what's his last name
I can't remember the last name but Jason
who created that plug-in has actually
been with us on the live chat several
times and helped us work through how to
set it up so really good plugin and it
it did save us because I mean I I
wouldn't want to have to do all the PHP
work to make graph QL work with
WordPress I just I don't know a lot
about PHP and I'm not really interested
in learning more about it right now
there's nothing wrong with PHP but I
just want to focus on getting better at
JavaScript let's see Alexi says do you
like front end more than back end
I don't know that's stuff quick I guess
I like front end right now more than
back end because all right it's easier
for me because that's where I started
out at and you immediately get to see
the results and show other people the
results and they can say like oh that's
cool
if you try to explain what you've done
on the back end of people who don't
really know about it they don't really
understand what's going on and then they
so I don't know like it's just you get
more positive feedback in things from
from people with front end stuff so I
don't know but it's not like I dislike
back-end like trying to choose between
the two is really tough for me right now
it's like asking me what child I liked
the best right um yeah so I like both
maybe one day I'll make up my mind about
which one I really like the best but I
can't right now I did I like working
with both that's Alexi says I guess
started using react and I have no idea
what I'm doing I'm more of a back-end
guy yeah that's how it is I think
depending on where you started the you
know moving to the other side of things
is always like more difficult so like
for me front end seems easy and back-end
seems hard but for a back-end person
sometimes front-end seems hard like I'd
I have an uncle that's been a software
developer for I don't since like the
late 70s or something and he does a lot
of stuff with c-sharp and well when we
talk and I'm telling him about some of
the stuff I'm doing he's always like
really impressed I'm like listen you've
been doing this for so long you know
I've got nothing on you and but he said
he said no like I work with the backend
stuff this stuff's all new to me and
it's all you know impressive so I kind
of like that just to keep that in mind
sometimes I don't like the tendency for
like some types of
programmers to look down on other types
of program as it says stuffs easy right
back-end people say oh well the
front-end you know that's the easy stuff
or whatever because really it's
nothing's easy in encoding in
programming right it all takes hard work
and it takes hard work to be really good
at it so it's just different for
different types so there are certain
things that you have to worry about in
front-end that you don't have to worry
about back in and vice versa
so anyway that's that's how I feel about
it
Evo says not the angular questions we
may not ever do anything angular on this
stream so you might not get the
questions James Ross says have you ever
considered Gunnar glasses or flux for
your eyes you know what I used to use
flux I have considered the glasses I saw
some I follow a lot of coders on
Instagram and I saw some of them had had
just purchased some of those glasses or
they got it as a present or something
for Christmas and I just got to thinking
about them does anybody use those or
know about them are they really helpful
for eye strain like oh my office is
always dark I keep the lights dim and it
cuts down on glare on my screens I try
not to keep my screens too bright to
help out with it but like I can tell
like right now my eyes are fatigued you
know I'm on a screen I mean you all know
how it is like we're looking at a screen
all day you know we and even when we're
not working you know you got phones you
had televisions right I mean we haven't
Nintendo switch for Christmas so like
I'm up at night trying to sneak in some
time with the new Zelda game while my
kids are yeah so if they're if they work
I'd
I'd be interested in getting some I
never wore glasses though might drive me
crazy to actually have them I I mean I
guess would be like sunglasses so
wouldn't be too bad Umberto's says I
love Magna doodle
yeah Magna doodle was cool I was never
good with Magna doodle I like to do it
but some people drew like amazing things
with Magna doodles
it just takes like a lot of coordination
and patience though let's see
Evo says I didn't hear anything about
technical questions from my recruiter
but I wouldn't be scared about those I
usually estimate my capacities as
somebody with one year working
experience thanks for the offer though
oh cool yeah no problem like I said I
don't know how much I could help you out
anyway I'm just excited James Ross says
lite-brite is extreme choking hazard
yeah but my little one Cordelia is my
youngest right a year and a half she's
so cute but she's the orneriest little
baby and man it's just like she'll put
some in her mouth that she's not
supposed to walk up to you and open her
mouth and let you see it and then run
away like she's dared you like Hey look
what I have I'm not supposed to have it
come Chase me right it's just but she
just looks so cute when she does it you
can't get mad that's like I love that
little girl she's just like I spoil her
so much I can't she she wants me all the
time this morning when I dropped my wife
had to drop me off at work because my
car is not working right now so Cordelia
was in the car
and I waved goodbye to her and as soon
as the car drove off she just started
crying and screaming I was like the
worst thing is broke my heart but just
she wants she wants me around all the
time
anyway sorry for the side for the side I
mean anybody and if you ever had a
little one or something yummy I'm sure
you you understand but it's just crazy
out add little
in there just you know you'd do anything
for them and they you know they're
they're like kind of helpless without
you but anyway not coding related sorry
let's see sin says go see hyper j/s this
is super hot
what's hyper jeaious I haven't heard of
hyper gayest Rumble Rose says it's
basically the same thing I've been
thinking I've been doing lots of backend
work for my own business for the last
two years so I've got lots of projects
built for portfolio that's cool I mean
having a good portfolio is where it's at
I mean that's what people are looking
for what projects have you done if when
we hire people here that's all I want to
know I could care less about your resume
I only read the cover letter to make
sure that people are literate and I I
want to know like where's the projects
let me see him let me see the code
oh cool Jeff Miller says that they do
still make light brights and his
daughter got one a few years ago awesome
I'm gonna have to check in on that not
right now I'd like to get one for my
office I wonder if they make little ones
that would be safe because Cordia is
rarely in my office
YouTube said I thought I click this to
see some coding oh yeah cue tube usually
at the end of the stream we do Question
and Answer so like the first hour we do
mostly like coding and then the second
hour is mostly question-and-answer I was
thinking about doing some more stuff
with this today but I don't know cuz the
streams getting really long now which is
fine the question answer is good so we
might not do any more code if you want
to see the coloured part check out the
recording of the video and just watch
like the first hour
well I take it back skip the first 15
minutes because we had technical day
qualities and then what's the the next
hour after that Vince says I've been
around long enough to remember watching
that commercial on TV
SJ says yeah I was born in late 80s yeah
I was born in 85 so I still like vaguely
remember 80s stuff and really like most
of my childhood that I remember was from
the 90s
Vince's instant response to Alexi I
started out as a back-end database
developer before I knew anything about
the web and I definitely liked front-end
better I'm sure opinions differ okay
that's that's interesting all right so
Vince started with back-end moves the
front-end and likes front-end so yeah I
think it's good to try both and see what
you like and then different people are
just gonna you know prefer front-end or
back-end or like both alright James Ross
says which of your children is your
favorite he said okay it's Cordelia I
love they're all so different it's crazy
that they're all like they all had like
the same set of genes going in right and
now they're all so different so yeah it
depends I mean the depending on how a
certain child is acting I may not like
them that much at that moment but
overall you know I just have a great
time with them and even as they get
older they change so much oh they all
different personalities so you know it's
just so hard to make that make that call
my wife is different than my wife will
tell me like this is my favorite child
right now you know she knows exactly and
it's usually based on which child gave
her a hard time that day and whichever
one didn't is the favorite one John
Hanson says a good perspective Jessi
problem-solving is the key to all sides
of coding all they're good at important
cool
I'm glad you agree John Henson says they
do make a travel-size lite-brite oh
that's going on my Amazon wishlist right
after this dream for sure
cat dee says what if your portfolio is
it to do that project and a hello world
project cat it's better than nothing so
here's what I think some people say
don't put like the your your projects
like your tutorial projects on github
but but here's what I think if that's
all you have put it on github because it
proves that you've actually done some
coding later on when you get some real
projects then you might want to make
those projects private or or take them
off get up I really don't even worry
about it to me here's the way I feel if
I see somebody that wants to work here
and they have real projects mixed in
with tutorials that tells me that
they're continuing to learn right and
they're not too good for tutorials
anymore alright and I like that I
appreciate that because if I find a dev
that isn't learning any more I don't
want to work with that dev no matter how
good they are right now
in two years they're gonna be terrible
because they won't have kept up with
anything so so cat go with that if you
can but try try your best to get some
some other projects on there you know as
soon as you can you know before you
really start trying to apply for places
and they don't have to be paying
projects they could just be some side
project that you really like or you
could try to contribute to other
people's projects so like you can
contribute to the projects that we work
on I try to make some issues like easier
for beginners to just learn the process
of submitting a pull request on github
so if you're interested in doing that
let me know you can message me on
Twitter or something and I could help
get you some more info I mean if you
already know how to do it that's cool I
don't want to assume that you don't but
if you need more help let me know or
find some other project that you really
like and see if there's something you
can contribute to because employers will
see that too you know they'll see a
record of your contributions even if
it's not your own project hopefully that
helped let me know if those wasn't
helpful or if it was confusing or
anything and I'll try to clarify then
says if you curious originally Oracle
PLC cool developer for a phone company
Oh interesting interesting I've never
done anything with Oracle SJ says I
actually have special lighting in my
office that's specifically designed for
offices where the computer users spent
hours on the computer it's really good
for the eyes oh that's that's actually
pretty cool maybe I'll have to look into
that I mean I really should think about
this if I'm going to be a programmer for
the next I don't know till I retire
right um I should probably think about
the effect it's gonna have on my eyes
long-term Hemet said please say
something on full stack with react I
have to finish voting app for free code
camp
I know react but I'm confused to use
react or not yeah so I would say for
react like you can do full stack
JavaScript right so and you could use
react on the front end and then node on
the backend react works a little bit
server-side as well so you can do
server-side rendering with react and
then serve those pages and then
potentially do client-side routing and
stuff you know once everything loads in
the browser so you can do some things
like that for your project I don't think
that would be necessary to actually do
server-side rendering unless you really
wanted to but I definitely think it's
it's a a good idea to do full stack
JavaScript all the way across it just
makes sense you know you learn one
language and you're able to do front-end
and back-end I think that's cool if you
got to learn something else for
project that's fine too right like we
use PHP sometimes but if you're trying
to learn and start out and being able to
do things then you'll save a lot of time
by learning JavaScript and being able to
write it on the front and the back end
so I mean if you have the time and you'd
like to learn more about react it might
be really cool to try to do that voting
app with react and set up the backend
with node if you're more comfortable
with something else though and you just
need to get it done then you know go
with that I don't think there's any real
reason why you really really would want
to use react for that but I really like
using it I think it's improved the
quality of my work and I think it's fun
to work with once you you know once you
get the hang of it I really enjoy it
Vince says it looks like you're about to
wrap up and I have to go anyway I
enjoyed this though I'll look for your
last ship again if I can thanks oh
you're welcome this thanks so much I
really enjoyed talking with you on the
live chat so yeah hopefully you can come
back for another another stream sometime
Hamlin said I saw some tutorials they
use two servers it's confusing yeah yeah
we use two servers sometimes for some of
the things we do so basically you'd have
a back-end server that's nodejs and it
it handles it can handle things like
like routing data like grabbing data
from a forum or something and sending it
off emailing it or you know using it
with an API and then you would have
another server that would just run your
react app so usually like if you have an
API or something then you know you want
to run that as a separate server you
don't have to I suppose trying to think
out
like you could let me say this way you
could have all the code in one project
right and all one one github project but
you would still want to run that
separately right like you one run
something on let's say port 3000 that
would be like your react and then on
port 8080 you'd run your API and then
like locally you could just hit that API
you know on that port and then when you
actually go to put that into a
production setting right you would still
run you know your server on on a
separate port right and then you could
just hit that from within the same
server if you wanted to and then have
like your client sites that are you
react stuff publicly available hopefully
that's not super confusing but I would
say like yeah having two servers when
you need like a back-end in the front
end is not unheard of oh cool cat Dee
says yes very thankful Thanks all right
all right cool I'm glad I could glad I
could help
all right so I've gotten to the end of
the live chat I definitely don't really
want to go any longer with this because
we're already over two hours with a
stream which is fine but I think it's
really intimidating for people to see a
video that's two hours long and said wow
I'm not gonna sit through two hours so I
like to keep it somewhere between one
and two hours and don't go much over
let's see it says Oh a manual said I
don't understand all right let me know
what you don't understand I'm assuming
that you're talking about like when I
was talking about running two different
servers let me know if that's the case
and and I'll try to I can pull up a repo
where I ran two different servers if if
you want to see an example let me I'm
gonna yeah all right let me pull up our
repository that I did actually run two
servers with
so let's go - I don't think it's you
know I profile I'll make everything
bigger so you can see it as soon as I
find the repository and it was there we
go all right so this was one of my
projects that I did when I was doing the
react nanodegree
[Music]
you know what actually I think I had the
server two different spots so this
project I was the first cohort to go
through so they changed it a little bit
when I first started this project they
had the server separate and then a
couple weeks later when I check back
again they had changed it as servers
actually in the same repo but at that
point I was almost done with the project
so I didn't switch it over so basically
here's what you would do this is your
react app right and if I go into source
here you can see I have you know just
like a normal index dodge ass and
everything and then over here this is
the API server where all the data is so
you have this server ejs file so what
you do is you'd start this up and then
I'd be able to get posts I'd be able to
create posts and have them stored here
and I could get posts I could edit them
but I still had to run this and let me
see where I had you see if it's my
reducers you know it's utils so you can
see where I'm hitting that API oops I
forgot to make the textbook font size
bigger sorry about that all right so
here like we're hitting that API so I'm
running the server on localhost 3001 I'm
hitting that API to get the data so like
this just grabs all the posts
this one gets posts from a certain
category this one actually gets just one
post based on an ID this one obviously
deletes a pose so you can see like we're
hitting that API that a separate server
from this app this app would run you
know its own
on its own server right so or you know
in this case on its own port on
localhost so I think this one would
probably run on 3,000 and then we had
the API running on three thousand and
one so this is not unlike what you would
do in a lot of production ops I mean
like right now we are getting the data
from from WordPress through graph QL so
that runs on it's a whole separate thing
and then in react which we're running
locally we're grabbing that data right
so we have to set up there if you were
to do JavaScript full stack you would
have the same set up you would make some
sort of an API to manage your content
and that would be running and then you
would have somewhere else
probably a react app that would run and
it would run so that clients could could
hit that you know with their browsers
you know users but it would grab the
data from the API so I mean I think it's
it's a common thing but just when we're
talking about JavaScript and going at
all in JavaScript it can be confusing
like why do we need two different no two
different ones so anyway that's why do
you absolutely need two different
servers probably not I mean think about
you just think about the way WordPress
works normally normally you do
everything just in WordPress itself it
hits the database you use PHP to put
together everything and then it spits
out markup to the client right but a lot
of sites now are drawing data from
separate api's so anyway so that's
that's kind of what I was trying to
explain
all right Emanuel says ok I think I
grasped it now we'll read more on it
all right cool cool yeah thanks for the
question too because I'm sure there are
others that
or either watching now or will watch
later that probably were confused too
I'm sure I didn't do a great job
explaining it but hopefully that maybe
just helps you out a little bit and now
you'll know like what to look up to read
more about it alright so I am going to
stop streaming now see tomorrow's
alright I'd pretty sure I don't have
anything lined up for tomorrow so I
should be able to stream sometime around
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time and will most
likely be coming back here working on
the same project again
we'll see how much I get done between
now and then maybe we'll pick up with
the same same spot
let's see Oh a manual said oh you did a
great job that's why I have a stay stay
with you all right cool
just thanks so much you're welcome
you're welcome I appreciate you saying
that
just I'm glad I could help alright so I
am yeah I'm gonna wrap things up I'll be
back tomorrow and until then thanks for
watching have a great day